so I'm just taking a freezing cold ice
bath and if you wanna benefits of this
if you want to know why wim HOF ice mat
recommends that you do this regularly
then stay cute please stay tuned or I
did this for nothing
[Music]
wim HOF is among the people with the
strongest claims to the title superhuman
this is a guy who can control his own
nervous system at will and his immune
system to a lesser degree he can
withstand extreme cold and has
demonstrated the ability to raise his
own physical strength and endurance as
needed
he holds 26 World Records in 2007 he
climbed 22,000 foot to the top of Mount
Everest wearing only shorts and shoes he
also ran a full marathon in the Arctic
Circle wearing only shorts with no prior
training in temperatures as low as minus
20 degrees Celsius for a normal person
the body temperature would drop so much
in just a few seconds in this water the
death would almost certainly follow and
what makes him really interesting is
that he claims that anyone can learn
these abilities by applying his wim HOF
method this is a breathing technique
combined with a regimen of cold exposure
and meditation that wim claims can help
you to take conscious control over your
own nervous system and physiology that's
why I'm experimenting with ice cold
baths to try and gain that same ability
it better be worth it there are legions
of loyal fans to back up his claims not
to mention numerous studies and all
those smashed records the only problem
is that the explanation of how all this
works is a little strange at times so
let's take a closer look and see just
what is going on here as well as what
you need to know to start benefiting so
the wim HOF technique involves three
basic steps first is controlled
hyperventilation here you take 30 deep
powerful breaths in Words inflating the
lungs each time then you passively
release the air simply allowing you to
escape naturally before taking the next
deep breath in this process should have
a steady rhythm and if you're doing it
correctly you should notice that you
feel a tingling in your legs and
extremities
and maybe that you go a little
lightheaded it's very important that you
perform this while stooping down
somewhere safe do not perform this in
the bath or anywhere else with the risk
of drowning four men have lost their
lives this way
next is exhalation after those cycles
you're now going to take one last deep
breath in and then let it escape slowly
all the way until you feel a strong urge
to breathe back in then comes retention
you breathe in and you hold that breath
for around 15 to 20 seconds you might
feel a head rush and you can repeat this
whole process up to three times but I do
recommend easing your way into it and
starting with just one now immediately
after this experience you should try
sitting and reflecting for a moment
meditation is also a key component of
the wim HOF method to take this moment
to enjoy the sense of calm and maybe
even a little bit of euphoria
once you feel already and you're
definitely not going to pass out then
you can try stepping into a cold shower
and you should find it doesn't freeze
you in quite the same way you might even
feel as though the water is warm
[Music]
so did the breathing exercise and I'm in
the water and yeah it's cold and I can
definitely feel it
I would genuinely say that that it's
less painful than it probably would have
been had I not just done that breathing
exercise however it's not really a fair
test if I'm just sitting waist-deep I'm
gonna have to go deeper okay here goes
I've actually been doing this for a
little while but I've been doing it with
cold showers and working out outside in
the cold this is the first time limit
ice bath water freezing cold baths and
that's why I was a little bit worried
about how that would go but I must say
I'm really impressed it hasn't been
horrible at all in fact I feel quite
good and I'm just up here not in a huge
hurry to jump out which is very unlike
me who used to have a big problem with
the cold
unfortunately my ice froze into a single
block of ice it doesn't have quite the
same visual appeal but I can tell you
for certain this was definitely a very
cold bath likewise if you have to try
and perform press ups now or lift a
heavy weight then you could notice an
increase in strength this is especially
true if you try performing press ups
during the breath hold not only that but
you'll now also feel more awake more
alert and more focused so what's going
on here a lot of people will tell you
that the effect is a powerful
demonstration of the importance of
oxygen that breathing in is deeply
filling the cells with oxygen actually
though they've got it all backwards
in fact the wim HOF technique works by
reducing our ability to utilize oxygen
what happens when you take those deep
breaths in is that you're filling your
lungs with oxygen and exhaling carbon
dioxide carbon dioxide normally reacts
with water to create carbonic acid and
this then makes our blood more acidic
like lemonade therefore when you use the
wim HOF technique and you exhale co2 you
raise your blood pH and make it more
alkaline this can lead to constriction
of blood vessels and reduced calcium
levels hence the pins and needles
researchers from Radboud University
Medical Center refer to the status
intermittent respiratory alkalosis what
many people don't realize
that lowering blood pH also prevents
hemoglobin from offloading oxygen stores
in short by lowering co2 you actually
prevent the body from being able to
properly utilize oxygen your blood is
saturated with oxygen but to all
extensive purposes you're in a state of
hypoxia unable to use it this is why
hyperventilation can cause us to pass
out normally likewise we to keep
performing the controlled
hyperventilation process for too long it
would eventually cause you to pass out
this could be dangerous and that's why
it's so important to practice caution
when using the wim HOF method in the
program wim emphasizes this a lot
himself that's why the breath hold is a
stroke of genius it allows carbon
dioxide to once again build up in the
body and now the blood is saturated with
oxygen that it can use and blood pH
therefore returns normal about 85
seconds into the hold this entire
process also stimulates the production
of adrenaline and noradrenaline the
hormones that we associate with the
fight-or-flight response this is the
body's panic response to a lack of
available oxygen and that effect occurs
via this stimulation of the vagus nerve
this is the longest of the 12 cranial
nerves and literally translates to
wandering nerve referring to its
branching nature that sees its arms
reaching the neck chest and abdomen it's
job is to allow the body to monitor the
state of various bodily processes and
this feedback in part allows for the
regulation of our sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous systems which in
turn control the fight-or-flight and
rest and digest responses respectively
in short the vagus nerves job is to ramp
up and down the metabolism in response
to such things as temperature oxygen
levels input from the gut and more this
is a largely unconscious process or at
least it was until wim came along
stimulating a parasympathetic response
increases the production of
anti-inflammatory cytokines from an
evolutionary perspective it makes sense
that we'd want to suppress information
when running from lions and tigers this
is no time for a swollen ankle that
explains why it might be that
practitioners of WHM are able to prevent
an immune response when injected with
bacterial toxins thereby fending off flu
and cold symptoms additionally this has
potentially profound implications for
those suffering from problems associated
with inflammation and seeing as there is
a potential link between inflammation in
the brain and depression it might also
help to explain why some people find whm
helps them to feel so good and the
adrenaline might also explain why women
off practitioners claim they experienced
an increase in strength as well
adrenalin results in a short-term
increase in strength by increasing
muscle fiber recruitment studies showed
that even just shouting when training
can raise adrenaline to a sufficient
extent as to increase average strength
by as much as 31% the most extreme
version of this is something I've talked
about a lot before hysterical strength
the kind of superhuman surge of strength
that allegedly allows mothers to lift
cars off of their trapped children the
wim HOF method may just be the best
pre-workout going after all epinephrine
levels seen in whm practitioners have
been found to be even higher than those
seen in people about to take a bungee
jump so to put all this simply when you
use the wim HOF method you're
temporarily making your blood more
alkaline whilst also triggering
short-term surges in adrenaline and
other excitatory neurotransmitters but
these are just short-term benefits like
really short-term the real question is
whether regularly using the wim HOF
method has any utility beyond that EPO
is secreted in response to reduced
oxygen which stimulates production of
red blood cells improving the ability to
perform endurance tasks for long periods
over time our body adapts and we become
better at producing the CPA this has a
similar effect to high-altitude training
and is an example of said specific
adaptations to imposed demands by using
low oxygen as a stressor we're able to
trigger an adaptation and become better
at performing in that state
seeing as EPA was so sought after by
endurance athletes this has immense
potential for marathon training and the
like the next part of the wim HOF method
is cold exposure in your highly focused
and pumped state it becomes much easier
to endure the cold thus once any
lightheadedness is passed in your clinic
enjoy the sensation the next step is to
take a cold shower or bath in my case
maybe go and do some perhaps outdoors
cold exposure then contributes to
numerous additional long-term benefits
in one study it was found that exposure
to cold water at 14 degrees Celsius was
able to raise lymphocytes to a small
purse ignition degree it is thought that
once again cold is able to act as a
stimulus or stressor in order to train
the immune system to get stronger wim
also believes that continued cold
exposure over time will train the
vascular smooth muscle
aiding circulation and making
cold easier to bear with time this could
also lead to improved overall thermal
regulation the ability to adapt and
function at different temperatures this
also occurs through an increase in brown
adipose tissue brown adipose tissue also
known as brown fat is a type of fat that
helps to convert food into body heat
animals that hibernate actually have
higher levels of brown fat and when you
submerge yourself in cold that brown fat
is what tells your body to burn white
fat in order to heat your body back up
this might also mean wim HOF methods
could contribute to long-term weight
loss seeing as brown fat actually helps
to burn more calories in a study looking
at mice it was found that adding brown
fat would have results in weight loss
and improved metabolism but none of this
still quite equates to controlling your
own nervous system that's what I'm
really interested in and I wondered if
it's hyperbole surely you're just
inducing a minor panic attack and
calming yourself down again through
breathing that's not quite the
equivalent of gaining superhuman control
over your faculties but in fact there
are some possible explanations as to how
this training could help to accomplish
this for one subjecting yourself to icy
cold forces you to control your own
response you need to stay calm in order
to make the freezing air or water more
bearable and this in turn might make you
better and remaining calm in other
high-stress situations you're training
yourself to deal with any kind of
stressor becoming tougher and mentally
more Hardy and resilient moreover you
learn to recognize these different
states within your own body you learn
what being ramped up feels like and you
learn how breathing makes you karma this
may act as a form of biofeedback and
that in turn might establish enough of a
link between different triggers and the
responses they cause in the body one
piece of research has shown that simply
by getting participants to check their
heart rate once every three hours can
eventually result in their being able to
actively control it through thought
alone maybe being more aware of your
sympathetic nervous system can help to
gain greater control over that maybe it
could help you to eventually trigger the
calmed focus associated with a flow
state this makes even more sense when
you consider the meditative components
of the methods wim didn't stumble on his
method purely Baxton but rather after a
period of research and exploration he
drew inspiration from the base and
breathing and visualisation techniques
seen ng Tomo meditation that allows
Tibetan London
to gain control over their core body
temperature this is possible even to the
point that those nuns have been able to
dry out wet towels
I suspect that we've only just scratched
the surface of what our minds are
capable of controlling so overall what
can we take from this first whim is an
awesome nut secondly clearly there are
some potential benefits the cold
exposure and to the breathing technique
that said I also think it's wise to
practice just a little caution starving
the brain of oxygen may sound alarming
and for a good reason
listen to your body and don't get to the
point where you're likely to pass out
wimp constantly stresses the importance
of not pushing the method you definitely
shouldn't try it if you have any
pre-existing health conditions and I
urge you to do your own research still
it's very cool and it's very interesting
for me I'm just beginning a new training
routine that involves training outdoors
in the cold at 7:00 a.m. I'm in the UK
and we're heading into November so it's
going to be cold I'm hoping this is
going to toughen me up in itself but
I'll be combining it with the wim HOF
method to hopefully get even greater
benefits I'll let you know how that goes
so I hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like please comment down
below let me know if you've tried the
wim HOF technique what you think of it
any other tips that I missed and stay
tuned for more like this I've got lots
more on the way I'm gonna be looking at
how to assess a health study I'm gonna
be looking at lessons we can learn from
our farts [ __ ]
and Houdini and from some other cool
legends I'm gonna be looking at Ninja
Warrior training how to jump higher
single leg strength if all that sounds
cool then stick around and I'll see you
next time thanks a ton for watching and
bye for now
[Music]